[Musik]
was nun da scholz was nun herr
bundeskanzler der letzte
sozialdemokratische
verteidigungsminister peter struck hat
den bundeswehreinsatz in afghanistan mit
dem legendären satz begründet
deutschlands freiheit wird am hindukusch
verteidigt
18 jahre später wird deutschlands
freiheit jetzt in der ukraine verteidigt
erstens peter struck hatte damals recht
dass er war es auch wichtig dass wir
nach dem furchtbaren anschlag auf das
world trade center solidarität gezeigt
haben un-soldaten mit vielen verbündeten
nach afghanistan geschickt haben auch
wenn es jetzt auch richtig ist dass der
einsatz zu einem ende gekommen ist denn
auch mit dramatischen auswirkungen in
dem land weil es eben nicht gelungen ist
eine stabile regierung dort zu
etablieren das euro geld vorhanden kann
und was für die ok was für afghanistan
damit gegolten hat gilt auch hier
natürlich kämpfen die ukrainerinnen
ukraine führe ihr recht auf staatliche
souveränität und auf demokratie freiheit
und rechtsstaatlichkeit und das ist auch
unser anliegen geht es um die freiheit
der ukraine oder geht es um die freiheit
deutschlands und wenn es um die deutsche
freiheit deutschlands ginge müsste das
ja auch heißen der bundeskanzler muss
die bevölkerung darauf einstimmen noch
mehr zu tun wir tun sehr sehr viel das
will ich ausdrücklich sagen wir haben
unser bündnis verpflichtungen in der
nato und das habe ich im deutschen
bundestag sehr klar gesagt wer das nato
territorium angreift der muss damit
rechnen dass wir alle gemeinsam dieses
territorium jeden zentimeter verteidigen
und in sachen der ukraine habe ich
entschieden als der krieg von putin vom
zaun gebrochen wurde als er mit
unglaublicher militärischer brutalität
die ukraine gefallen hat dass wir mit
einer jahrzehntelangen politik brechen
und in dieses krisengebiet in die
ukraine waffen liefern was wir seither
mit großer intensität tun wir haben
zuallererst gesagt dass wir aus unseren
beständen liefern wir haben dann gesagt
wir machen eine vereinbarung mit der
industrie und liefern das was dort
sinnvoll genutzt werden kann und die
industrie liefern kann wir haben uns
verpflichtet zusammen mit
osteuropäischen partnern zu arbeiten die
russische und sophia tische kriegswaffen
nutzen können vor einem panzer die in
der ukraine im gebrauch sind und die die
schon kennen wo die logistik hätten und
die ausbildung stimmt und machen dann
die unterstützung dadurch dass wir
unsererseits mit westeuropäischen gerät
diese länder die lage versetzen ihre
verteidigungsfähigkeit aufrecht zu
erhalten das machen übrigens die usa
oder frankreich italien spanien
großbritannien genauso wie wir wir haben
dann gesagt dass wir jetzt auch noch
zusätzlich etwas tun wegen der konkreten
ausgestaltung des konfliktes jetzt im
osten der ukraine in dem wir sagen wir
werden zur luftverteidigung
gippert liefern was eine notwendige
entscheidung war angesichts dieser
entwicklung und wir arbeiten mit den usa
zusammen was artillerie fragen betrifft
und den niederlanden sie sagen keine
alleingänge was die militärführung bild
haben sie allerdings durchaus in den
letzten wochen ja einen zurückhaltenden
kurs vertreten haben ja auch argumente
dafür geliefert zum beispiel das eben
vermieden werden muss einen dritten
weltkrieg vom zaun zu brechen jetzt
liefert deutschland schwere waffen auch
schwere waffen sie sprechen die gepaart
panzer an und zu dem vorwurf sie seien
zu zögerlich kommt jetzt noch ein
anderer vorwurf nämlich von
pazifistischer seite die sagen ist das
jetzt hier nicht militärische aufrüstung
oder gar kriegstreiberei was ist ihre
linie vielleicht durch steht da auch
einfach unsicherheit haben sie das
zögern aufgegeben überhaupt nicht ich
habe immer schnell entschieden zusammen
mit allen anderen mich mit den
verbündeten abgestimmt aber mein kurs
ist schon dass wir besonnen und mit
klarem verstand handeln dh es gibt hier
keine entscheidung die danach gemacht
werden kann wie sie jemand in
irgendeiner pr-abteilung entwerfen mag
immer noch was drauf oder niemals etwas
was sie jetzt zuletzt angesprochen haben
so das muss jede einzelne entscheidung
sorgfältig abgewogen werden und ganz
klar ist unsere hilfe die wir geleistet
haben die finanzielle und die
militärische mit den rüstungsgütern die
wir in die ukraine geliefert haben und
liefern werden die hilfe die auch viele
andere länder zur verfügung stellen
haben dazu beigetragen dass die
ukrainische armee die wirklich sehr
erfolgreich agiert
jetzt so lange durchhalten kann gegen
einen übermächtigen gegner und wir
werden sie dabei weiter unterstützen mit
jeder entscheidung ist verbunden dass
wir immer überlegen was hat das für
weitere konsequenzen
deshalb macht es keinen sinn und
besonnen zu handeln deshalb macht es
keinen sinn dass man etwas tut nur weil
die jemand laut ruft oder etwas nicht
tut weil irgendjemand laut ruft man muss
das tun wozu ich an amtseid geschworen
habe nämlich dafür sorgen dass wir hier
den frieden sichern und dass wir
gleichzeitig auch unser land zu schützen
was sind die konsequenzen sie haben da
durchaus auch die sorge vor einem
atomkrieg ins feld geführt als argument
und dann aber drei tage danach deshalb
will ich noch mal nachfragen doch dann
der lieferung schwerer waffen zugestimmt
da hat dass der eine oder andere nicht
mehr verstanden war das argument gar
nicht so stark oder gar nicht richtig
oder wurde der druck einfach auch zu
groß vor dem treffen den randstein jetzt
noch mehr zu tun ich glaube dass das
eigentliche problem ist dass einige sich
auf begriffe fixieren wie zum beispiel
schwere waffen wo wir hier ein
vierstündiges seminar darüber abhalten
könnten was das wohl wer seit haben ja
jetzt nicht handle nicht deshalb sage
ich mal gibt es ja ein paar sachen die
wir klar sind deshalb forderung gegeben
wir sollen schiffe liefern oder
kampfflugzeuge oder u-boote hat es auch
gegeben verschiedene sachen und deshalb
ist doch nicht die antwort schwere
waffen oder nicht machen wir liefern
ziemlich gefährliche waffen von anfang
an wenn ich dass man dazu sagen darf und
wir erwägen aber bei jeder entscheidung
welche konsequenzen das hat und ob das
überhaupt nutzt aber die öffentlichkeit
hat uns ganze hat doch den eindruck
gewonnen im inland und im ausland zum
beispiel die entscheidung den gebhard zu
liefern das hat einfach lange gedauert
sie haben auch die argumente immer
wieder gewechselt haben neue argumente
gefunden anderer zurückgenommen und
nochmal sie haben den höchsten
moralischen druck aufgebaut mit dem
verweis da gibt es die gefahr des
dritten weltkriegs sind sie eigentlich
ihrem eigenen anspruch gerecht geworden
ein bundeskanzler zu sagen der klare
führung zeigt ja und die führung besteht
ja daran dass in jedem der laut ruf und
falsche argumente verwendet nach gebe
sondern dass ich sehr klar sage was der
kurs ist und den habe ich eben
beschrieben in der reihenfolge der dinge
die wir machen und ich will ausdrücklich
dazu sagen wir haben jetzt immer wieder
entscheidungen getroffen die sich aus
dem konkreten kriegsgeschehen ergeben
und die auch etwas damit zu tun haben
dass sie vernünftig sollte das heißen
hat scholz dass nach dem gepard dann
doch noch irgendwann der leopard kommt
was sie bisher ausgeschlossen haben ich
will dir mal was sagen dass vielleicht
wichtig ist weil es so selten berichtet
wird was wir tun in hinblick auf
kampfpanzer zum beispiel ist die gleiche
entscheidung die die usa getroffen haben
und die anderen die ich eben alle
aufgezählt habe alle wissen übrigens
auch in den usa wie in deutschland auch
jeder der es wissen will dass es bei den
dingen die wir liefern mehrere aspekt
gibt einer davon ist können die damit
überhaupt was vernünftiges anfangen weil
sie dafür ersatzteile haben weil es da
im munition gibt weil man darauf
ausgebildet er seit der gap hat ist auch
kompliziert und jetzt nehmen wir das
gleiche argument für den leopard der ist
da geht es um ungefähr 50 stück das ist
etwas was man bewältigen kann und eine
ganz andere dimension ist als die dinge
die sonst diskutiert worden sind und
noch mal ich sage ausdrücklich der
fehler beginnt wenn man sich mit dem
rhetorischen wort schwere waffen
überhaupt aufhält denn das ist etwas wo
kein mensch was mit anfangen kann und
was einen davon weg führt eine konkrete
entscheidung zu treffen die vernünftig
ist im hinblick auf die aspekte die für
uns bei der wahrung des friedens wichtig
sind und damit ich der frage nicht aus
weil hier die sie gestellt haben es
machen sich in diesem land ganz viele
bürgerinnen und bürger viele von denen
die uns jetzt hier zu schauen große
sorgen dass es eine eskalation des
krieges gibt die über die ukraine hinaus
geht und sie machen sich diese sorgen ja
auch durchaus berechtigter weise deshalb
habe ich von anfang an gesagt es wird
keine beteiligung der nato und auch von
deutschland an diesem krieg unmittelbar
geben der amerikanische präsident hat
das seinen bürgerinnen und bürgern
gesagt viele andere auch wir haben
zurückgewiesen als mit der gleichen
werbe mit der jetzt diskutiert wird über
diesen begriff diskutiert worden das ist
so eine flugverbotszone eingerichtet
werden was bedeutet hätte unmittelbare
kriegsbeteiligung der nato und das will
ich ausdrücklich sagen die letzten jahre
und jahrzehnte ist es uns gelungen in
einer atomar hochgerüsteten welt den
frieden zu bewahren weil am ende alle
genügend rationalität hatten um zu sagen
eine direkte konfrontation zwischen nato
und russland wird vermieden sie sagen
erklären ihren kurs was ist denn das
ziel was die ukraine fordert ist ja klar
mehr gerät auch mehr schweres gerät mehr
panzer was ist das ziel der deutschen
militärischen beteiligung
sie haben immer gesagt putin darf nicht
gewinnen aber heißt das auch die ukraine
muss russland besiegen sagen sie dass
auch unser ziel ist dass es sofort zum
ende der kampfhandlungen kommt dass
russland den krieg beendet und seine
soldaten aus der ukraine wieder
zurückzieht und das was ich formuliere
ist ganz bewusst so gesagt dass ich sage
russland darf nicht gewinnen und die
ukraine darf nicht verlieren wir müssen
zurückweisen dass jemand im schlimmsten
stil des imperialismus des 18 19
jahrhunderts sagt mein territorium ist
nicht groß genug die grenzen sind
gefallen mir nicht die waren früher mal
anders und mit waffengewalt versucht das
zu ändern das ist dass die ukraine soll
siegen soll gewinnen weil sie wissen das
ist gar nicht möglich oder das heißt
dass es dem einen oder anderen verborgen
geblieben ist aber ich sag es deshalb
noch mal klar russland ist eine der
hochgerüsteten nuklearmächte der welt
eine weltmacht auch in diesem sinne und
deshalb muss es unser ziel sein dass
diese politik nicht gelingt die
letztendlich heißt die nachbarländer
sind mein hinterhof da bestimme ich was
da passiert und wenn da was geschieht
was mir nicht gefiel gefällt dann komme
ich mit gewalt das muss zurück und
verloren hat putin wenn er seine truppen
von ukrainischem territorium zurück er
hat überhaupt seine ganze operation
nicht zu ende gedacht denn erstens hat
er
nicht gedacht dass die ukraine an
solchen widerstand leistet er hat nicht
gedacht dass wir sie militärische
unterstützen dass sie so lange
durchhalten kann er hat nicht gedacht
dass so viele länder und deutschland hat
ja zusammen mit den usa noch vor
kriegsausbruch den großen teil der
sanktionen vorbereitet so viele länder
sanktionen verhängen gegen russland die
unmittelbar wirksam sind und was er
immer noch nicht bedacht hatten dass
wenn er jetzt vielleicht sich beschränkt
und dann bin ich nicht sicher ob das du
es auf eine teil eroberung in der
ukraine und dann die waffen einfach
aufhören zu sprechen und nicht mehr
geschossen wird und alles bleibt so wie
es ist dass er dann immer noch nichts
gelöst hat für sich denn wir werden ja
und das ist der fehler in seinem kalkül
wir werden ja ohne ein einvernehmen mit
der ukraine nicht die sanktion wieder
aufheben er muss sich mit der ukraine
einigen und das wetter nicht mit einem
diktat frieden hinkriegen dass wir das
nicht hinkriegen wenn er einfach seine
bedingung vorschreibt und sagt nimmt sie
jetzt bitte machen sie es mal ganz
kurzer scholz aus der sicht deutschlands
aus der sicht der nato ist das ziel dass
sich putin zurückzieht aus dem
territorium der ukraine
das steht der ukraine zu und deshalb
unterstützt und wie sie in ihrem
verteidigungskampf wir wollen nicht dass
jetzt hier einfach mit einem solchen
einsatzgebietes gewinne militärisch und
erzielt werden und es dann dabei bleibt
einschließlich der krim wir werden nicht
akzeptieren dass die krim annektiert
worden ist das war ein völkerrechts
bruch das haben wir schon seinerzeit
gesagt als ganzes land und auch
parteiübergreifend das bleibt auch
richtig und ich will das noch einmal
dazu sagen die friedensordnung die wir
in den letzten jahren und jahrzehnten in
europa entwickelt haben beruht auf der
idee dass die grenzen nicht mit gewalt
verschoben werden und schon die annexion
der krim war ein bruch mit diesen
prinzipien der amerikanische
verteidigungsminister hat ein weiteres
ziel formuliert an scholz nämlich das
ziel sei nicht der regime change also
kurz gesagt putin muss weg sondern eine
dauerhafte strategische schwächung
moskaus das nie mehr zu solchen
angriffen auf nachbarländer in der lage
sein soll teilen sie auch die system
unser ziel muss sein dass die ukraine
ihre souveränität ihre freiheit und
ihren wunsch in einem demokratischen
land zu leben verteidigen kann dafür
unterstützen wir sie unser ziel muss
auch sein dass russland mit diesem
vorhaben nicht durchkommt dass es nicht
klappt was sie sich vorgenommen haben
das ist das ziel das wir jetzt haben und
das ist schon schwer genug wie wir jeden
tag sehen wenn wir diese grauenhaften
bilder aus der ukraine
gemeinsam verfolgen die uns ja alle tief
ins herz führen und die uns alle
umtreibt
dabei helfen sollen jetzt vor allem die
sanktionen die sollen ja putin zum
aufgeben bewegen inzwischen wird über
ein sechstes sanktionspaket gesprochen
dass wird vorbereitet wie schnell kann
ist jetzt ein öl-embargo
geben
deutschland hat die lieferung
zurückgefahren der wirtschaftsminister
sagt das können wir jetzt verkraften
aber andere länder sagen dass eben nicht
ungarn jetzt gerade heute blockiert ja
offenbar wie schnell kann jetzt ein
öl-embargo com und hilft es dann
eigentlich bewirkt es noch was diese
aktion die wir bisher verhängt haben
sind vor allem die wirksamsten
insbesondere die finanzsanktionen
sanktionen gegen die zentralbank bei
einem so großen starts das in der
vergangenheit noch nie gemacht worden
das muss man sich immer noch mal klar
machen dass wir technologie exporte nach
russland verhindern was dazu führt dass
die wirtschaftlichen entwicklungschancen
russland perspektivisch
verloren gegangen sind das es
zurückgehen wird wirtschaftlich und
ökonomisch im hinblick auf die letzten
jahre und da machen wir stück für stück
weiter bei fossilen importen haben viele
länder deutschland auch ausgangs weise
ein großes problem nämlich dass wir die
nicht von einem tag auf den anderen
ersetzen können und da wir von
vornherein uns auch international
verständigt haben dass wir keine
sanktionen verhängen die uns mehr
schaden als russland waren die nicht
dabei heißt dass das öl immer gut das
kommt jetzt noch nicht so schnell hin
ganz blockieren wir haben um das auf
deutschland bezogen erst mal zu sagen ja
schon im dezember angefangen uns mit der
situation zu beschäftigen dass es
passieren kann dass wir nicht mehr
beliefert werden das war eine der ersten
fragen die ich gestellt habe als ich ins
kanzleramt kam weil ich angesichts des
militärischen aufmarsches rund um die
ukraine herum der ja immer so aus als ob
es auch eine rolle in version der
gesamten ukraine geben das ist es mir
leid aber das kann ja was wir noch nicht
wissen ist ob die einheit der eu die bis
jetzt gehalten hat weiter hält oder ob
jetzt die bruchstelle ist weil ungarn
sagt die das öl embargo machen wir nicht
mehr die einheit der eu ist in der tat
wie sie sagen sehr weitreichend dazu
haben wir einen ganz bescheidenen
beitrag geleistet und werden das auch
weiter tun und trotzdem will ich ihnen
noch mal sagen wir haben schon damals
gesagt wie bereiten wir uns darauf vor
und deshalb konnten wir sagen wir können
allmählich aus der kohle raus wir können
etwas schneller auf öl verzichten wir
wissen aber um die noch ungelösten
probleme die es bei raffinerien im osten
deutschlands gebe und die sind auch noch
nicht gelöst und wir werden
längerfristig auch mit den gasimporten
zurechtkommen können dass wir auf die
verzichten bei den letzteren müssen wir
aber noch richtig pipelines bauen und
lng terminals damit das funktioniert
womit wir angefangen haben dass alles
auf den weg zum ganzen sätzen auch
schwieriger aber ich wundere mich jetzt
warum sie dreimal die frage märkte im in
game werbung also es ist alles so
unsicher jetzt im moment dass sie war
nicht einfach ich finde dass es so eine
live ticker meldung aus europäischen
beratungen geben sollte das kein
fußballspiel da geht es um die einheit
der europäischen union wo wir uns
miteinander darüber die lehre
gemeinsames problem sie gehen voran aus
unserer sicht geht es im wesentlichen
darum dass wir unseren eigenen beitrag
leisten und der eigene beitrag besteht
darin dass wir uns seit langer zeit
darauf vorbereitet haben jetzt wie wir
stück für stück auf diese importe
verzichten können und wir wissen wie
schwierig das ist dass er wissen wir
auch wie schwierig das für andere länder
ist und das muss jetzt zu einem
gemeinsamen konzept erwachsen und da
setze ich darauf dass wir das gemeinsam
die sachen diskutieren lösen werden beim
thema gas ist es nicht so einfach zwar
füllen sich die gasspeicher wieder bei
uns aber die arbeitnehmer die
arbeitgeber sagen wie industrie wenn es
jetzt zu einem embargo kenner oder zu
einem lieferstopp aus russland dann
würden zehntausende vielleicht
hunderttausende arbeitsplätze in gefahr
sein wie lange wird und wie lange muss
deutschland noch ein russisches gas
abnehmen auch wenn das bedeutet wir
pumpen viele milliarden in das system
putin und finanzieren damit putins krieg
so wie sie es gesagt haben
olive wie es immer in deutschland liefe
dann würden wir das noch viele jahre
müssen wir glauben dass wir das aber
unglaublich beschleunigen können deshalb
haben wir die ganzen projekte die schon
seit vielen jahren geplant war jetzt
angestoßen dass sie auch umgesetzt
werden haben wir uns auch selber bereit
erklärt uns finanziell zu beteiligen um
das möglich zu machen wir haben wie sie
nachlesen konnten schiffe mit dem man
die reklassifizierung von flüssiggas für
das partnernetz vornehmen kann geordert
damit sie angeschlossen werden an die
neu entstehenden pipelines und unsere
hoffnung ist schon dass wir damit sehr
viel schneller fertig sind ich schaue
mich ein wenig eine feste aussage zu
machen bei etwas das sonst viele jahre
dauert aber wir sind ja noch wir sind so
ehrgeizig dass wir glauben dass sich
einige noch umgucken werden wie schnell
das geht wenn man über russisches gas
redet mit der spd müssen wir auch über
gerd schröder sprechen spd-altkanzler
aber eben vor allem inzwischen putins
treuester gas lobbyist möchte man fast
sagen warum ist das problem noch nicht
gelöst
sie müssen sich neue interviews anhören
von gerd schröder der doch eher
diametral zu ihnen argumentiert wie
machen sie da jetzt weiter er ignoriert
aufforderungen als iran hat ja sagen
warum es das problem noch nicht gelöst
das finde ich sehr lustig wenn ich das
so sagen darf ehrlicherweise weil wir in
einem freien land leben und der
bundeskanzler seinem vorgänger keine
befehle geben kann was ich aber eben gar
nicht verhehlen will ist dass ich das
nicht richtig finde dass ich glaube dass
man auch nach dem amt als bundeskanzler
eine verpflichtung hat die dem amt folgt
dass man einmal hatte ist eine große
ehre bundeskanzler zu sein und das hat
auch konsequenzen für die zeit wenn man
das amt nicht mehr ausübt und ähnlicher
weise finde ich ist völlig unvertretbar
spätestens
seit dem kriegsbeginn unmöglich dass der
frühere bundeskanzler diese aufgaben
weiter deshalb frage ich dass das können
sie doch so nicht hinnehmen oder sind
sie am ende doch ein bisschen milder
weil sie denken vielleicht kann gerd
schröder doch noch mal hilfreich sein
ich habe das was ich ihnen hier gesagt
schon habe schon früher gesagt ich finde
er sollte seine ämter dort aufgeben und
das wiederhole ich gerne zu unserer
sendung gehört die satz ergänzung sie
kennen das herr scholz wir geben einen
halbsatz vor und sie ergänzen ihnen
möglichst kurz und der erste halbsatz
lautet heute dass manche überrascht sind
dass ich auch brüllen kann
liegt wahrscheinlich darin dass die
digitalisierung nicht so weit
fortgeschritten ist dass alle schon
meine auftritte als junger politiker
weil aufgezeichnet in der weise sekretär
das annalena baerbock und robert habeck
als die besseren krisenmanager
wahrgenommen werden wir sind eine
regierung und ich freue mich über alle
minister die als teil dieser regierung
viel zustimmung bekommen
mit angela merkel habe ich zum thema
ukraine zuletzt telefoniert das werde
ich ihnen nicht sagen aber wir
telefonieren
meine eigene krisenkommunikation bewerte
ich mit der schulnote und die küche gar
keine schulnote ich finde dass es hier
darum geht dass es sehr ernste sachen zu
lösen gibt und dann muss man auch
ernsthaft bleiben wenn der russische
präsident putin im november am
g-20-gipfel in indonesien teilnimmt
wir werden
bis dahin entscheidungen treffen müssen
die da etwas mit zu tun haben es geht
aber um eine internationale
zusammenarbeit struktur bei der es ganz
wichtig ist dass wir nicht vergessen wer
alles noch als bündnispartner haben
wollen heute hatte ich
indien zu gast habe ich noch zu gast und
spreche mit dem indischen
regierungschef ich habe sehr guten
kontakt aufgenommen zudem regierungschef
vom indonesien indonesien ist jetzt g20
sehen putin ein daten würden sie sich
mit ihm an einen tisch setzen
die antwort müssen sie schon ertragen um
das ganz klar zu sagen ich habe sie noch
nicht gehört
indonesien ist eine demokratie in denen
es eine demokratie das sind unsere
bündnispartner
und wenn wir den westen und die leute
mit denen wir verbündet sind auf
diejenigen konzentrieren die das schon
anfang des letzten
jahrhunderts waren als westen dann sind
wir zu kurz gesprungen es heißt das
heißt dass scholz will indonesien putin
einlädt und der kommt dann setzen sie
sich mit ihm an den tisch wir werden
darüber entscheiden wenn es soweit ist
alles andere wäre ziemlich unklug aber
ich will ausdrücklich sagen dass es auch
unklug wäre
nicht zu verstehen dass wir wenn wir die
demokratie global verteidigen wollen wir
einen schweren fehler machen wenn wir
sie für eine lebenskultur des westens
zeiten das hat etwas mit unseren
vorstellungen als menschen und mit der
humanität zu tun und die demokratie wird
deshalb global stark weil wir verbündet
sind mit den ländern die ich zum
beispiel zum g 7 gipfel nach elba
einlade nämlich indonesien indien
südafrika und senegal und noch anderen
ländern aus dem süden amerikas die uns
genauso wichtig sind sie hatten elf
wochen im amt eine zeitenwende zu
verkünden dass so haben sie es ja
genannt und diese zeitenwende beinhaltet
durchaus auch jetzt eine neujustierung
der außen und sicherheitspolitik das
hören wir schon sie hat hierzulande
natürlich noch mehrere komponenten zb
100 milliarden sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr die festlegung
2% für verteidigung auszugeben und
dagegen gibt es ja jetzt durchaus auch
widerstand nachdem am anfang alle so
gesagt haben alles richtig was wäre
bundeskanzler da sagt von den grünen
gibt es kritik an dem zwei prozent ziel
von den gewerkschaften gestern die
kritisieren aufrüstung zu lasten eines
sozialen friedens wenn sie sich darüber
aber solche kritik hinwegsetzen na ja
wir hatten ja schon mal das gespräch
geführt eben über die frage von
leadership und führung es ist meine
aufgabe das jetzt durchzusetzen
angesichts der tatsache dass der
russische präsident uns nun
unmissverständlich mitgeteilt hat nicht
nur in deutschland
das ihm recht und regeln egal sind wenn
er sich mächtig genug fühlt dann setzte
sich darüber hinweg müssen wir dafür
sorge tragen dass wir als nato als
europäische union stark genug sind uns
gegen jeden angriff zu verteidigen und
das hat für das größte land der
europäischen union mit der größten
wirtschaftskraft und auf dem
europäischen kontinent auch der größten
militärisch kraft die wir jetzt schon
repräsentieren natürlich die konsequenz
dass wir mehr tun müssen damit das auch
funktioniert und ich will ihnen gerne
sagen jeden tag den ich mich intensiv
beschäftige mit der bundeswehr und wie
sie ausgestattet das bestärkt mich darin
dass es völlig richtig ist die
bundeswehr braucht mehr erzählt und sie
bleiben auch bei ihrer zusage dass auch
das sozialpaket aus dem
koalitionsvertrag noch umzusetzen es
trotz aller kosten die da auf uns
zukommt bei einer inflation von über 7%
ja dann alles dafür tun dass wir eine
starke wirtschaftliche entwicklung haben
dass das auf dem arbeitsmarkt gut läuft
das will ich nicht alleine unsere hand
aber die zahlen sind ja trotz der
gegenwärtigen schwierigen lage
gegenwärtig ganz gut und wir können
alles dafür tun dass wir die große
modernisierungsphase unserer
volkswirtschaft jetzt schnell
vorantreiben da geht es um das aufhalten
des menschengemachten klimawandels und
die energie transformation so dass wir
auf erneuerbare energien setzen können
und damit auch unabhängig werden zb von
russland aber es geht auch darum dass
wir natürlich in einer zeit in der so
viele herausforderung auf uns zukommen
auch die gesellschaft zusammenhalten
müssen und das wollen wir stichwort
führung der oppositionsführer friedrich
merz fährt jetzt nach kiew und er sagt
er fährt auch deshalb weil der
bundeskanzler immer noch nicht da war
hat er diese reise mit ihnen eigentlich
abgestimmt gibt es da vereinbarungen
werden sie ihn empfangen und sich
berichten lassen welche wünsche er aus
kiew mitbringt also erstens hat er mich
über seinen wunsch informiert und ich
habe da keine anwendung und sie billige
dass zweitens ist es so dass wir
natürlich auch hinterher über das was er
mir mitzuteilen hat sprechen werden
alles andere wäre kein guter umgang in
der demokratie in der wir miteinander
bringen was wir glaube ich für die
zukunft
dann fahren sie gegebenenfalls mit dem
französischen präsident ich finde dass
es doch immerhin ein ganz
bemerkenswerter vorgang ist dass der
präsident der bundesrepublik deutschland
damit eine mehrheit wie glaube ich
niemand vor ihm in der bundesversammlung
wenige wochen vorher für eine zweite
amtszeit nominiert worden ist ausgeladen
worden ist das steht dem immer noch
entgegen da sind der sache das steht der
sache im weg was wie kann das ausgeräumt
werden erstmal glaube ich muss es für
uns als demokraten demokraten dazu
gehören dass wir über diese sache kein
zweifel haben das kann man nicht machen
und es kann nicht funktionieren dass man
von einem land das so viel militärische
hilfe so viel finanzielle hilfe leistet
das gebraucht wird wenn es um die
sicherheitsgarantien geht die für die
zeit der ukraine in der zukunft wichtig
sind dass man dann sagt der präsident
kann aber nicht kommen dann hören wir da
raus der präsident müsste zunächst
kommen danach würden sie sich
wahrscheinlich richtung teams bewegen
gedanken sehr wir müssen darüber und
über andere themen sicher noch weiter
reden vielleicht in einem neuen was nun
das war es für heute vielen dank für ihr
kommen herr bundeskanzler vielen dank
für ihr interesse liebe zu schauen und
zuschauer hier geht es jetzt weiter mit
wie so einen schönen abend auch jazz aus
berlin
noch geht es nicht weiter mit wiso
sondern hier bei uns mit der analysen
denn wir können jetzt sprechen über eure
fragen alles was ihr wissen möchtet und
dieses interview mit meiner kollegin
nicole diekmann sie ist korrespondentin
in berlin im hauptstadtstudio und uns
jetzt zugeschaltet hallo nicole
nicole du hast natürlich auch im gerade
das was nun geschaut und natürlich
zunächst die frage an dich welche figur
hat den aufstand abgegeben wo er doch
solange jetzt wirklich in der kritik
stand
ja olaf scholz ist da gerade aufgetreten
als jemand der sagt der krieg ist sehr
schlimm was putin macht ist sehr schlimm
aber die innenpolitische situation hier
in deutschland
die ist nicht schlimm und die kritik an
mir ist unangebracht das war der rote
faden der sich durch dieses gespräch
gezogen hat und er wurde aber auch
natürlich darauf angesprochen auf sein
zögern das zögern im verlauf eben dieses
krieges das zögern deutschlands
kritische waffen zu liefern hat er da
irgendwas geliefert um die kritik zu
entkräften
aus seiner sicht bestimmt es gibt drei
argumentation strenge der er sich
bedient das eine ist das kennen wir ja
mittlerweile schon das ist das berufen
auf bündnisse auf auf die nato auf die
eu auf die g7 dass er also sagt keine
alleingänge schauen sie auf die anderen
staaten wie die agieren deutschland
macht damit deutschland tritt nicht
hervor ist nicht singulär sondern immer
in abstimmung mit den partnern auf die
sich berufen muss das zweite ist dass
scholz von zögern gar nichts hören will
das ist nichts wie er sich selber sieht
er gesehen werden möchte sondern er sagt
ich habe einen amtseid abgelegt als
bundeskanzler deutschlands schaden
abzuwenden fernzuhalten und deswegen ist
jede entscheidung eine
einzelentscheidung die sehr gut
abgewogen sein möchte und das ist jetzt
neu gerade in diesem gespräch ohne stolz
sagt es war ganz interessant
definition schwere waffen sind gemäss
hat er gesagt wie definiert man den
schwerer waffen also apple überhaupt
keinen widerspruch sehen zwischen einem
großen interview das er gegeben hat und
in dem er vor allem möglichen atomkrieg
gewarnt hat und das als argument gegen
die lieferung schwerer waffen an geführt
hat und der erklärung der entscheidung
drei tage später oder wenige tage später
im bundestag nun doch zum beispiel
gepanzert die ja als schwere waffen
gelten zu liefern an die ukraine da sagt
er
da bräuchten wir es mal ein
vierstündiges seminar in dem wir uns
auseinandersetzen müssen was bedeutet
denn eigentlich schwerer waffen also das
lässt er nicht auf sich sitzen will er
nicht auf sich sitzen lassen und bindet
das eben mit diesen drei argumentation
streng ab ich sehe auch schon hier ein
paar meinungen bei uns im stream ich
möchte kurz aufgreifen gerhard renz bei
facebook schreibt olaf scholz hält kurs
er wird nichts unüberlegtes gemacht ist
es wird nichts unüberlegtes gemacht und
die besonnenheit von olaf scholz ist
völlig angebracht in dieser krise ist er
der richtige mann am richtigen platz und
am richtigen ort dagegen schreibt nico
wolf bei youtube der werte herr scholz
kann die waffenlieferungen schön reden
wie er will beziehungsweise kann sagen
dass deutschland und die nato sich nicht
aktiv einmischen fakt ist wie russland
und putin diese aktionen werden wir
haben natürlich auch uns noch mal ein
paar töne raus geklammert aus diesem
interview urlaubs sagte zum einen also
oder ist der meinung deutschland tour
genug um den krieg in der ukraine zu
stoppen er meint ja und wir hören jetzt
mal kurz noch in einen ausschnitt des
interviews rein geht es um die freiheit
der ukraine oder geht es um die freiheit
deutschlands und wenn es um die deutsche
freiheit deutschlands ginge müsste das
ja auch halten der bundeskanzler muss
die bevölkerung darauf einstimmen noch
mehr zu tun wir tun sehr sehr viel das
will ich ausdrücklich sagen wir haben
unseren bündnisverpflichtungen in der
nato und das habe ich im deutschen
bundestag sehr klar gesagt wer das nato
territorium angreift der muss damit
rechnen dass wir alle gemeinsam dieses
territorium jeden zentimeter verteidigen
und in sachen der ukraine habe ich
entschieden als der krieg von putin vom
zaun gebrochen wurde als er mit
unglaublicher militärischer brutalität
die ukraine befallen hat dass wir mit
einer jahrzehntelangen politik brechen
und in dieses krisengebiet in die
ukraine waffen liefern was wir seither
mit großer intensität tun wir haben
zuallererst gesagt dass wir aus unseren
beständen liefern wir haben dann gesagt
wir machen eine vereinbarung mit der
industrie und liefern das was dort
sinnvoll genutzt werden kann und die
industrie liefern kann
er sagte dass wir mit einer
jahrzehntelangen politik berechnen und
in dieses krisengebiet in die ukraine
waffen liefern was wir seither mit
großer intensität tun die kritik der
opposition und auch der ukraine selbst
hier spricht ein bisschen eine andere
sprache konnte er die entkräften heute
ja ich würde sagen er hat heute nicht
viel neues gebracht an argumenten bis
auf das was ich eben gelernt habe also
zusage schwere waffen ist quasi den
begriff
olaf scholz verfolgt eine eigene logik
in dem was er verbringt und nochmal er
ist fest davon überzeugt er zumindest
wenn er wenn er nicht davon überzeugt
verkauft er ist zumindest sehr gut nach
außen
dass er einen sehr festen inneren
kompass hat dem er die ganze zeit folgt
und der eventuell nicht für jedermann
von außen sichtbar ist er hat es ja
gestern in düsseldorf auch zum ersten
mal klar gemacht da war ja relativ
ungewohnt kämpferisch und laut für seine
verhältnisse eher muster laut sein weil
im jahr viel kritik in form von buhrufen
von von brüllerei muss man sagen von
schiffen entgegen
entgegengeschlagen ist da hat er klar
gesagt es ist aus der zeit gefallen das
war das zitat die ukraine nicht mit
waffen zu beliefern das heißt er stellt
sich als jemand da der tatsächlich einen
großen politischen schritt geht indem er
eben als regierungschef zustimmt schwere
waffen in ein kriegsgebiet zu liefern
was man ja in der tat die letzten
jahrzehnte in deutschland nicht getan
hat und sagt ich hab das ja gerade schon
einmal gesagt er lässt sich weder von
der einen noch von der anderen seite
beeinflussen in seinen entscheidungen
weder fand die sagen es muss jetzt
langsam mehr werden es muss auch
schneller gehen noch von der anderen
seite die sagt frieden schaffen ohne
waffen um das war zusammenzupacken du
hast die situation gestern angesprochen
scholz rede bei der ersten mai
kundgebung in düsseldorf und da haben
wir auch einen einspieler und können mal
kurz in dieser situation von gestern
reinhören
[Musik]
[Applaus]
respektiere der haltung aber es muss
einen bürger der ukraine schildes
vorkommt die besorgte solle sich gegen
die polizeiaktion ohne waffen
verteidigen was ist aus der zeit
gefallen
genau das war die szene du hast sie
angesprochen hat er denn diesen menschen
die also diese sorge äußern die auf der
pazifistischen mit einer pazifistischen
argumentation kommen hat er denen denn
etwas beruhigung heute geben können
durch sein interview durch das was er da
gesagt hat
er hat das erwähnt er hat den menschen
in diesem land erwähnen die sich große
sorgen machen darüber dass es einen
dritten weltkrieg geben könnte in der
dann auch deutschland hineingezogen
werden würde eventuell das ist ja die
große frage
wir haben das letzte woche gesehen und
zdf politbarometer da ist tatsächlich
die bevölkerung ziemlich gespalten das
ist fast 50 50 dass die einen sagen es
muss mehr passieren und die anderen
sagen nein vorsicht wir haben eben angst
davor in einen krieg mit hineingezogen
zu werden und diese letztere fraktion
hat er eben auch angeführt als einen
grund für sein handeln also
zusammengefasst hat er hat uns stolz
eben gesagt wir müssen der ukraine
helfen es ist unsere pflicht der ukraine
zu helfen nicht nur mit wie er sagt viel
geld und viel militärischer
unterstützung
aber auf der anderen seite ist es die
unbedingte pflicht seine unbedingte
pflicht als kanzler so sagt er das den
krieg fernzuhalten von deutschland er
hat sich natürlich zu vielen themen in
diesem halbstündigen interview geäußert
wir werden auch noch im verlauf dieser
sendung auf dem energie sanktionen zu
sprechen kommen und auch noch auf die
militärische ja halb militärische
haltung strategie deutschland jetzt da
möchte ich aber kurz noch auf einen
punkt mit ihr eingehen er hat sich
nämlich auch geäußert zu mehr geld für
die bundeswehr und trotz inflation und
grundsätzlich zu seiner politik und den
finanzen in deutschland würdest du uns
das nochmal einschätzen was da heute von
ihm kam dazu
ja die frage war er hat es auch heute
noch mal bestätigt bekräftigt die frage
von bettina chancen kamen sie glaube ich
war sind denn die sozialen projekte ist
noch genug da ist noch genug dafür die
wie man so sagt sozial schwächeren
wenn all dieses geld jetzt investiert
wird auch vor dem hintergrund einer
inflation von 7 und da sagte scholz und
später fiel auch das stichwort sozialer
zusammenhalt der gesellschaftliche
zusammenhalt also das ist tatsächlich
die
gratwanderung die diese regierung und
diese ampel koalition jetzt schaffen
muss einerseits sehr viel geld
auszugeben und das besondere ist ja sehr
viel geld das man überhaupt nicht
vorhergesehen hat ja 100 milliarden euro
zusätzlich für die bundeswehr geld für
die ukraine vor zwei wochen hat man noch
mal eine zusätzliche milliarde
beschlossen an militärischer hilfe für
die ukraine einerseits also
unvorhergesehene sehr große summe
aufzutreiben und andererseits auf der
anderen seite nicht zu sparen da nicht
zu sparen wo es wichtig ist und eben den
sozialen zusammenhalt hier zu lande zu
gewährleisten wir würden auch nicht
vergessen
die korona pandemie ist jetzt ungefähr
zwei jahre im gange und wir haben große
verwerfungen gesehen hierzulande das
muss man auch einmal sagen unsere
korrespondentin in nordrhein westfalen
dort versagt die leute die da gestern
entgegen gebrüllt haben auf der mai
kundgebung in düsseldorf das waren vor
allem sogenannte querdenker das waren im
gegner das thema ist noch nicht vom
tisch das heißt diese
vielzitierte oft besondere soziale
spaltung droht immer noch schwebt immer
noch wie ein damoklesschwert auch über
dieser regierung das war schon zu
römerzeiten so das ist natürlich jetzt
auch nicht weg in den ampel zeiten im
gegenteil auch über die frage waffen für
die ukraine oder nein droht man sicher
zu zerstreiten wir hatten am wochenende
diesen brief von intellektuellen der
wird heiß diskutiert unter federführung
von alice schwarzer das muss man als
regierungschef als olaf scholz alles mit
einkalkulieren danke für diese schnelle
analyse direkt live aus berlin nicole
diekmann danke
gerne
der kanzler betonte russland darf nicht
gewinnen die ukraine darf nicht
verlieren aber deutschland hat lange
gezögert der ukraine schwere waffen zu
liefern wie olaf scholz heute dazu hört
mir hören noch mal kurz rein sie haben
da durchaus auch die sorge vor einem
atomkrieg ins feld geführt als argument
und dann aber drei tage danach deshalb
will ich noch mal nachfragen doch dann
der lieferung schwerer waffen zugestimmt
da hat dass der ein oder andere nicht
mehr verstanden war das argument gar
nicht so stark oder gar nicht richtig
oder wurde der druck einfach auch zu
groß vor dem treffen in ramstein jetzt
noch mehr zu tun ich glaube dass das
eigentliche problem ist dass einige sich
auf begriffe fixieren wie zum beispiel
schwere waffen wo wir hier ein
vierstündiges seminar darüber abhalten
könnten was das wohl wer seit haben wir
jetzt nicht handeln nicht deshalb sage
ich mal gibt's ja ein paar sachen die
wir klar sind es hat forderung gegeben
wir sollen schiffe liefern oder
kampfflugzeuge oder u-boote hat es auch
gegeben verschiedene sachen und deshalb
ist doch nicht die antwort schwere
waffen oder nicht machen wir liefern
ziemlich gefährliche waffen von anfang
an wenn ich dass man dazu sagen darf und
wir erwägen aber bei jeder entscheidung
welche konsequenzen das hat und ob das
überhaupt nutzt
wir können darüber sprechen jetzt mit
gustav gräßel erarbeitet am european
council on foreign relations beschäftigt
sich dort vor allem mit
sicherheitspolitik und militärstrategen
gehenden guten abend herr dressel
herr dressel haben den kanzler gehört er
ist der meinung über den begriff schwere
waffen könne man lange diskutieren und
deutschland hätte von anfang an zitat
ziemlich gefährlicher waffen geliefert
sehen sie das genauso
deutschland hat mit
kleinen waffen zu liefern und das war im
grunde alle westlichen staaten haben
damals schulter gestützte waffen oder
waffen geliefert die man leicht
verstecken kann die doch wenige personen
eingesetzt werden können die sozia
kriminalistischen kampf zu gebrauchen
sind und das hat er im grunde
hintergrund dass man erwartet hat dass
russland die erste phase des krieges
nämlich die usa ukraine das militär als
organisierten widerstand gibt relativ
schnell gewinnt manche haben von tage
gesprochen andere haben von wochen
gesprochen aber es war kaum eine
prognose die mehr als drei wochen den
ukrainern gegeben hätte und da hat man
waffen geliefert die auch in einem
guerilla kampf oder dem widerstandskampf
gegen eine russische besatzungsmacht
verbindungsweg werden und das sind
natürlich dann nicht waffen die eine
große logistische kette brauchen und
dass er nicht waffen
für den einsatz und der haltung man viel
infrastruktur braucht das hat sich
natürlich jetzt geändert also die
ukraine ist jetzt nach 65 tagen oder 66
tagen sehr weit davon entfernt das ganze
ist erobert zu werden und der krieg wird
sich das verbot in die ukraine als
ganzes immer noch erobern will dann wird
sich diese kriege auf jeden fall ins
nächste jahr ziehen selbst wenn er jetzt
in dombach in dieser erfolgsrate
weitermacht also jetzt kann man
natürlich jetzt haben wir die
möglichkeit schon ganz andere dinge zu
liefern man sieht sich auch im bereich
der vorbereitung des trainings ganz
anders aus als zu beginn dieses krieges
und damit ist eigentlich der verschwenkt
in die vereinigten staaten und
großbritannien das erste vollzogen haben
in richtung beschwere komplexere
waffensysteme da
das was deutschland jetzt liefert an
luft ob der panzern ist der sogenannte
gepard wieso hat man sich für den
entschieden
hier gab es ja auf der auf dem
luftwaffen stützpunkt in ramstein eine
große konferenz alle 40 staaten die die
ukraine mit rüstungsgütern und beliefern
und hat sich mal angehört was die
ukraine braucht was in welchen
zeithorizont braucht und wer was wann
liefern kann es ist nicht so dass die
ukraine zb alles sofort braucht die
ukrainische verteidigungsindustrie wurde
halt leider in den letzten wochen
systematisch zerbombt aber damit ist die
ukraine abhängig von
lieferungen aus dem ausland allerdings
bei gewissen rüstungsgütern hat man auch
die eigene munition haben noch eigene
vorher den vehikeln die relativ lange
dauern und bei manchen klassen geht es
relativ schnell aus und man ist auf
dringende hilfe aus dem ausland
angewiesen und jetzt vermeidet man sich
ok wo gibt es in europa was welche firma
kann was produziert in welchen
zeithorizont müssen wir reden und da
bliebe nebenbei deutschland die gepaart
übrigen mich hat das auch aus deutscher
perspektive eher überrascht weil er
relativ komplexes waffensystem ist an
dem man viel ausbilden muss aber wenn es
in den anderen kategorien andere
europäische staaten oder andere staaten
im nordatlantischen bündnis gibt die
schnell liefern können die mehr liefern
können dann kommen die da zum zug und
dort wo es und sagen wenig hände nach
oben gehen da halt an deutschland und
das blieb daneben angepasst das muss man
im grunde so stehen lassen akzeptiert
wir waren ja alle im raum ständig dabei
und haben uns angehört was andere
staaten da liefern können und es gibt
sehr wenige gepanzerte selbstfahrende
systeme die in der nato noch verfügbar
sind und die überhaupt lieferfähig sind
in dem sinn kam deutschland mit dem
gebet zum zug die ukraine fordert ja die
ganze zeit moderne westliche
waffensysteme was jetzt ja nicht dabei
ist ist also der panzer leopard machen
wir genug aufsicht natürlich der ukraine
dass die antwort wahrscheinlich nein
aber sie als experten schätzen sie das
ein
aber ich bin mittlerweile ein bisschen
beruhigt da sich das selber vor vor zwei
wochen noch war die die realität ist die
ukraine eben jetzt nur mit mit
westlicher unterstützung überleben kann
die ist damals noch bei wenigen leuten
ein gesunken mittlerweile ist das
common sense innerhalb der nato
beim leopard reden wir hier vom neuen
leopard 2 kampfpanzer wo die
produktionslinie im grunde schon
ausgebucht ist für das was für den
aufwuchs der bundeswehr in andere
europäische staaten geplant wird dann
wird es natürlich enorm schwierig reden
wir von gebrauchten leopard 1
kampfpanzer
dann ist da würde ich eigentlich wenig
gründe sind nicht in der ukraine zu
geben mit der ausnahme natürlich dass es
sich um ein relativ altes system
handelt das relativ schwach geschützt
ist
aber es gibt ja noch pionierpanzer es
gibt brücken die gefahren auf demselben
fahrgestell führt dass man ähnliche
ersatzteil und wir selber ersatzteile
verschleißteile motoren etc in der
ukraine bereitstellen muss
beziehungsweise die leute zur wartung
händen schulen muss und wenn man dann
die pionierpanzer die brückenpflege
panzer herunter liefert oder auch dem
gepard kamera noch für sich den leopard
1 die alten leopard 1 auch drauf legen
aber das ist der sollte die frage von
was von was wir da reden ich möchte noch
mal die stimmung hier bei uns im stream
ein bisschen wiedergeben die ist sehr
unterschiedlich zum einen lese ich hier
unter anderem ein kommentar von 4 750
ich bin froh dass wir jetzt schwere
waffen liefern denn ich möchte nicht in
einem land leben das bei dem völkermord
in der ukraine und tätig wechselt
schreibt die person und dann lese ich
aber auch ne na.de seiner akte ich hoffe
das war richtig schrieb bei facebook wer
waffen liefert hat krieg im sinn hört
endlich mit dieser kriegstreiberei auf
das ist nicht unser krieg und wir wollen
und dürfen ihn nicht führen der krieg
wird nicht durch waffen beendet sondern
immer nur mit friedensverhandlungen und
kompromissen also hier auch wirklich
zwei sehr kontroverse meinungen dazu in
dem stream fakt ist deutschland hat
länger gezögert um schweren waffen zu
liefern
diese strategie strategie von scholz
nicht alles offenzulegen hilft oder
hindert das was würden sie sagen als
stratege
es haben sich alle variierten vereinbart
dass nicht alles kommuniziert wird vor
allem dass die langfristige planung
nicht kommuniziert wird auch um der
russischen seite keine rückschlüsse zu
darüber zu geben welche rüstungsbetriebe
sie in der ukraine schon zerstört haben
welche nicht in dem sinne bin ich bin
ich damit einverstanden ich hoffe
natürlich dass die bundesrepublik und
das zeug hier auch es gibt ja wieder
mehrere rammstein konferenzen geben sich
da auch immer dann mit den alliierten
wirklich abspricht oder nicht das war ja
vorher so dass der alleingang der
deutschen viel beschworene deutsche
alleingang ja nicht im waffen liefern
bestand sondern davor im nicht liefern
von gewissen waffen darin bestand und
ich hoffe dass das für diese phase jetzt
wirklich überwunden habe
was natürlich auch ein thema was wir
jetzt gleich zum ende der sendung auch
nochmal mit einer weiteren experten
intensiver besprechen möchten aber dazu
auch noch eine frage an sie also bislang
eben kein öl und gas embargo jetzt zum
thema energie sanktionen selbst wenn
jetzt 1 käme die frage an sie wäre das
dann zu spät
zu spät ist es ist nur so dass russland
desto länger die diskussion darum dauert
desto länger der karte auch nicht
erfolgt desto eher kann sich russland
darauf einstellen alternative
absatzmärkten eine alternative
transportmittel bereitzustellen das ist
bei bei kohle ist das relativ einfach
weil öl wird zum teil schwieriger weil
viel öl nach europa pipeline gebunden
exportiert werden und bei gas ist es um
alle schwierigsten weil gasexporte sehr
infrastruktur pumpen sind desto
schneller
im umkehrschluss natürlich jetzt ein gas
im barock ema desto härter wird es
russland treffen desto schneller
ölembargo käme das für hertha würde es
muss dann treffen und wir haben mit der
am leichtesten zu substituieren
energiequelle angefangen der kohle so
werden es eigentlich umgekehrt machen
soll aber das wird ja in europa leider
und sozusagen von rhein unter
wirtschaftlichen gesichtspunkten
diskutiert und nicht vor dem hintergrund
wie kann man die die russische kriegs
finanzierung am schnellsten unterbinden
vielen dank für diese einschätzung heute
abend militärexperte gustav presse
trainer zu ihnen dank und
wir kommen jetzt also auch zum ende in
der sendung zu einem weiteren wichtigen
punkt des interviews das thema
lieferstopp von russischem öl und gas
das war eben auch teil das was nun und
wir hören noch mal in einer antwort von
olaf scholz dazu rein zum thema gas ist
es nicht so einfach zwar fühlen sich die
gasspeicher wieder bei uns aber die
arbeitnehmer die arbeitgeber sagen wie
industrie wenn es jetzt zu einem embargo
käme oder zu einem lieferstopp aus
russland dann würden zehntausende
vielleicht hunderttausende arbeitsplätze
in gefahr sein
lange wird und wie lange muss
deutschland noch ein russisches gas
abnehmen auch wenn das bedeutet wir
pumpen viele milliarden in das system
putin und finanzieren damit putins krieg
so wie sie es gesagt haben
wenn es
olive wie es immer in deutschland liefe
dann würden wir das noch viele jahre
müssen wir glauben dass wir das aber
unglaublich beschleunigen können deshalb
haben wir die ganzen projekte die schon
seit vielen jahren geplant war jetzt
angestoßen dass sie auch umgesetzt
werden haben wir uns auch selber bereit
erklärt uns finanziell zu beteiligen um
das möglich zu machen wir haben wie sie
nachlesen konnten schiffe mit dem man
die reklassifizierung von flüssiggas für
das partnernetz vornehmen kann geordert
damit sie angeschlossen werden an die
neu entstehenden pipelines und unsere
hoffnung ist schon dass wir damit sehr
viel schneller fertig sind ich schaue
mich ein wenig eine feste aussage zu
machen etwas das sonst viele jahre
dauert aber wir sind ja noch wir sind so
ehrgeizig dass wir glauben dass sich
einige noch umgucken werden wie schnell
das geht und
darüber können wir jetzt sprechen mit
der wirtschaftswissenschaftlerin
professor doktor veronika krim schönen
guten abend gute name jungfrau krim ist
um sie nur mal kurz richtig einzelnen
filiale einzuleiten für unsere
zuschauerinnen zuschauern dass jeder
weiß wer sie sind sie sind seit april
2020 mitglied des sachverständigenrats
zur begutachtung der
gesamtwirtschaftlichen entwicklung also
sie sind damit eine der fünf
wirtschaftsweisen und schön dass sie bei
uns heute zu gast sind olaf scholz
sprach eben unter anderem davon
deutschland hätte schiffe angefordert um
diesen unabhängigkeit prozess zu
beschleunigen
aber er scheute sich davon ein konkretes
datum zu nennen ihre einschätzung wie
lange würde es dann dauern sich da jetzt
wirklich unabhängig zu machen von
russischem öl von russischem gas
insgesamt
ja ich glaube das sind ganz verschiedene
fragen wieder an rolle spielen die
diskussion ist ja sehr polarisiert es
geht ja zunächst einmal darum dass wir
die zahlungsströme reduzieren müssen das
muss das ziel sein das kann man mit ganz
unterschiedlichen maßnahmen machen da
kann man solle verwenden da kann man
treuhandkonten verwenden man kann auch
einen preis ultimatum verwenden also man
teilt nicht mehr als einen bestimmten
preis man muss das dann natürlich
juristisch sauber umsetzen auch auf
unserer seite für die deutschen
unternehmen aber es muss darauf abzielen
die zahlungsströme nach russland zu
reduzieren wir zahlen 20 milliarden euro
pro monat aus der europäischen union
anruf anpassungen für einen drittel der
staatsfinanzen dort und das ermöglicht
natürlich finanzielle spielräume die man
eben sonst nicht hätte und darauf müssen
die maßnahmen abziehen und ich glaube
die vorbereitungen auf einen solchen
lieferstopp bei gas die ist deswegen so
wichtig weil natürlich was auch immer
man tut um diesem entgegen zu treten und
um diese tat zahlungen zu reduzieren ein
lieferstopp von russischer seite kann
dann immer drohe und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass
in den griff zu bekommen
und da
sind sicherlich schwierigkeiten mit
verbunden bei öl heißt es jetzt wir sind
schon runter von 35 prozent anteil an
den deutschen öllieferungen auf 12 aber
diese zwölf betreffen fokussiert eine
raffinerie im osten deutschlands und das
ist natürlich die herausforderung das
würde sicherlich zu schwierigkeiten
kommen aber auf der anderen seite ist es
natürlich so wenn wir weiter zahlen
dann ist das natürlich auch etwas was
den krieg und die spielräume russlands
in die die spielräume russlands erhöht
diesen konflikt weiter zu eskalieren und
möglicherweise eben auch andere
regierungen auch auszudehnen also nicht
zu handeln kann eben auch mit kosten
einhergehen längerfristig und deswegen
ist es wichtig diese abwägung zwischen
den kurzfristigen kosten- und den
längerfristigen kosten das nicht weiter
handelns auch richtig zu treffen vermes
angesprochen bei den ölimporten ist
deutschland runter auf 12 12 prozent
aber innerhalb der eu sind da also
einige länder noch weit drüber sind da
eben viel abhängiger zuletzt waren da
eben ungarn österreich slowakei die sich
die da gebremst hatten bei den
sanktionen wie einig ist sich denn
europa denn das spielt ja auch eine
wichtige rolle deutschland alleine das
wird ja wahrscheinlich nicht reichen
ja deutschland alleine reicht auf keinen
fall man muss da sicherlich wirklich eng
europäesch zusammenarbeiten ist auch
wichtig dass auf der ebene der
europäischen union zu koordinieren
sowohl was eine entscheidung oder eine
zoll entscheidung betrifft als auch was
die bewältigung der ökonomischen
herausforderungen betrifft wenn denn
diese entscheidungen getroffen sind und
wenn es denn zu lieferstopp von öl oder
von gas kommen soll das ist ganz wichtig
da europäische zusammenzuarbeiten
und es ist nicht so ganz klar wieder die
bälle hin und her gespielt werden in
dieser diskussion hat man ja durchaus
den eindruck dass ich da auch der eine
hinter dem anderen versteckt deswegen
ist das sehr sehr schwer einzuschätzen
wie er jetzt tatsächlich dazu bereit ist
und wer nicht dazu bereit ist und es
gibt ja selbst unter den
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern der sehr
unterschiedliche haltung zu den energie
sanktionen und manche sind also da für
manche sind dagegen sie sind dafür warum
sind denn ihrer meinung nach energie
sanktionen der richtige weg
also ich denke dass es wichtig ist die
zahlungsströme zu begrenzen das kann man
mit unterschiedlichen maßnahmen tun ich
glaube ein zoll modell wäre aktuell eine
geeignete maßnahme ist man muss auch das
timing betrachten es ist insbesondere
wichtig relativ schnell die einnahmen zu
reduzieren nämlich zu einem zeitpunkt wo
die ukraine auch noch
handlungsspielräume in den kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen hat es ist ja
richtig jetzt die einnahmen zu
reduzieren und zwar zu einem zeitpunkt
wo russland noch nicht die möglichkeit
hatte alternative sich zu arbeiten wenn
wir abwarten und war sie noch ankündigen
dass wir zum beispiel gegen jahresende
aussteigen dann hat russland zusammen
mit anderen potenziellen abnehmern
natürlich die möglichkeit die neuen
handelsströme vorzubereiten und ein
embargo würde russland gar nicht so hart
treffen wie es russland jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt treffen würde wo eben diese
alternativen noch nicht
ermöglicht wurden und auch nicht so
schnell umsetzbar sind deswegen ist es
wichtig schnell zu handeln deswegen
haben auch viele gesagt die eben auch
die längerfristigen auswirkungen
geschaut haben besser schnell ein
embargo schnell oder die zahlungsströme
reduzieren mit geeigneten maßnahmen um
eben jetzt die finanziellen spielraum
russlands zu reduzieren das hätte auch
russland deutlich einschneidende
auswirkungen und auf jeden fall als auf
die europäischen volkswirtschaften aber
und da besteht unter ökonomen eigentlich
auch wenig des 1 es hätte auch
signifikante auswirkungen auf unsere
volkswirtschaften also die der
wirtschaftseinbruch dürfte zwischen 2 5
und 6 prozentpunkten
sein die man abziehen müsste von dem
aktuell prognostizierten
wirtschaftswachstum das so um die zwei
prozent liegt dh wir wären dann in einer
rezession in diesem jahr das kann sich
auch bis ins nächste jahr hinein ziehen
aber der staat müsste dann natürlich
seine fiskalischen spielräume nutzen um
die temporäre effekte eines solchen
start wenn zum beispiel unternehmen
aufgrund von geringeren verfügbarkeit
dann in einer bestimmten zeitperiode
nicht produzieren konnte musste das
abgefedert werden zum einen über
unternehmenshilfen und zum anderen auch
über kurzarbeitergeld wie umfangreich
diese engpässe sind das ist erstmal
nicht so ganz klar weil man muss sich ja
auch vorbereiten es gibt ja auch
gegenmaßnahmen dh der
wirtschaftsminister war ja schon in
aller welt unterwegs und hat sich um
ersatzbeschaffungen gekümmert also gas
mengen auf dem weltmarkt
kontrahiert so dass wir eben ein teil
der russischen liefermengen ersetzen
könnten wurde zum anderen kann das
verschiedene studien die darauf
hinweisen dass man auch einen großen
teil des gasverbrauchs einsparen kann
und die studien hinaus von bis zu 20
prozent des gasverbrauchs in deutschland
den man einsparen könnte sogar durch
kurzfristig realisierbare massnahmen 20
prozent ist eine relativ große summe
wahrscheinlich wenn man es wirklich
verschärft versucht kommt man nicht ganz
bis 20 prozent aber das zeigt einfach da
ist ein riesiges potenzial auch gas
einzusparen und wenn man sowohl
ersatzbeschaffungen organisiert als auch
einsparungen vornimmt dann bleibt dann
noch eine lücke aber die ist vermutlich
eben nicht so groß dass jetzt die
haushalte kalt bleiben müssen im
nächsten winter oder die produktion
komplett zusammenbricht das beantwortet
hoffentlich die frage von tempo lud bei
youtube der fragte eben wie hart würde
uns das embargo treffen aber trotzdem
noch mal nachgefragt es gibt da ja auch
expertinnen und experten die sagen zum
beispiel mit gas embargo es gibt es
bislang keine erfahrungen das könne man
nicht vorhersagen auch scholz sagte damm
in der vergangenheit eben auswirkungen
eines möglichen embargos in
irgendwelchen mathematischen modellen
zusammen zu rechnen sei unverantwortlich
dass würden sie dem dann entgegen setzen
genau zunächst mal es ist richtig dass
die unsicherheit relativ groß ist aber
die frage ist eben ob man angesichts der
unsicherheit von maßnahmen
zurückschreckt generell vor maßnahmen
zurückschrecken sollte die die zahlungen
reduzieren ich würde jetzt auch nicht
vorschlagen dass man sofort die
belieferung
boykottieren sollte also darauf
hinwirken sollte dass man selbst nicht
mehr willig versucht man sollte darauf
hinwirken dass man nicht diese immensen
summen zahlt russland hat ja gerade beim
gas auch nur das geliefert was
kontrahiert war und nicht mehr in einer
zeit wo die nachfrage sehr hoch ging
nach der korona krise also als die
nachfrage wieder zurückkam und hat
dadurch eigentlich strategisch
vermutlich die preise stark in die höhe
getrieben und dem sollte man sich
natürlich aus der europäischen union
auch entgegen stellen weil natürlich
jetzt auch geguckt wird wie reagieren
wir denn da drauf ist krupp der krieg in
der ukraine
wir zahlen immense summen an russland
aus der europäischen union und russland
und zum beispiel auch china schauen
natürlich ganz genau darauf wie wir uns
einschüchtern lassen wie erpressbar wir
eigentlich sind durch die abhängigkeit
von russischer energie oder auch durch
die drohungen dass man dann bestimmte
maßnahmen als kriegerische handlungen
interpretiert und wenn wir uns diesen
entwicklungen konsequent entgegen
stellen also nicht konsequent agieren
dann kann das ja durchaus auch
dazu führen dass die eskalation weiter
geht dass man sich einigen angefühlt
weiterhin mit waffengewalt seine ziele
durchzusetzen weil sich herausstellt aus
der beobachtung die europäer können sich
dann nicht einigen und reagieren nicht
das ist ja durchaus eine gefahr die im
man abwägen muss und da muss man abwägen
die langfristigen gefahren die dadurch
entstehen dass dem nicht konsequent
entgegentreten weitere eskalationen die
dadurch geschehen könnten und eben die
kurzfristige gefahr dass ein lieferstopp
erfolgt und wir dass es wirtschaftlich
abfedern müssen es gibt noch mehr fragen
an sie aus dem chat aus dem stream denn
natürlich also mehr die kosten werden ja
für uns steigen so viel ist natürlich
klar und deswegen fragt sich dann die
bei youtube frau grimm gibt es kleine
oder mechanismen die drohende inflation
hervorgerufen durch ein embargo
entgegenzusetzen also gibt es pläne oder
mechanismen mechanismen dem
entgegenzuwirken
generell muss man natürlich der
inflation entgegenwirken das ist auch
jetzt schon so wir haben ja jetzt schon
relativ hohe inflationsraten und die
inflation und gerade in diesen jahren
auch im nächsten jahr noch relativ hoch
bleiben das ist ein handlungsfeld für
die geldpolitik die geldpolitik muss
auch die inflationsraten reagieren
natürlich umso
moderater die wirtschaftsentwicklung
auch das duo schwieriger ist die lage um
auch geldpolitisch dem entgegen zu
wirken aber hier gilt natürlich wenn man
nicht eher politisch reagiert und die
inflation laufen lässt dann werden die
wirtschaftlichen verwerfungen deutlich
schwerwiegender sein als wenn man der
inflation entgegen tritt das heißt ja
dann immer man würde dadurch eine
rezession auslösen oder das
wirtschaftswachstum bremsen aber das
muss man durchaus den kauf nehmen weil
dann wie die inflation laufen lassen
dann wäre es eben für die wirtschaft
mittelfristig deutlich unangenehmer da
gibt es erfahrungen in den 70er jahren
die eigentlich zeigen wenn die inflation
erst einmal außer kontrolle gerät die
inflationserwartungen hoch gehen
sozusagen die menschen glauben auf dauer
werden die preissteigerungen sehr hoch
bleiben dann steigen die löhne dann gibt
es vorrat bevorratung also dann kaufen
die leute bevor es zu teuer wird und das
heißt dann alles die inflation weiter an
da muss die geldpolitik der inflation
entgegen treten und das wird auch meiner
meinung nach geschehen für einen öl
importstopp der zahl zeigt sich
deutschland ja offen können sie uns aber
vielleicht mal erklären öl oder gas
import stadt das sind ja dann doch noch
mal zwei paar schuhe was käme zuerst was
es kann dass ein konsequenter weg also
dass sie das nochmal für uns genauer
erklären ja ich glaube der konsequente
weg wäre dass man relativ schnell
versucht die zahlungen zu reduzieren wir
relativ schnell einen zoll
etabliert sodass
idealerweise rück behandelt wird und ein
großer teil der zahlungen die jetzt an
russland
getätigt werden durch diesen soll
reduziert werden mit den einnahmen
könnte man zum beispiel auf
hilfsmaßnahmen für die ukraine
finanzieren oder die folgen abwenden
wenn es dann dadurch zu einem
lieferstopp in der europäischen union
käme also das müsste man relativ schnell
machen ich glaube was nicht günstig ist
dass wir jetzt sehr sehr lange über ein
embargo reden und das dann auch noch
sehr sehr langsam umsetzen also stück
für stück die mengen reduzieren das
könnte nach hinten losgehen in der tat
in der tat weil man ja schon sieht umso
länger man darüber redet über einen
importstopp umso stärker reagieren
natürlich auf die preise und wenn die
preise nach oben gehen dann nutzt das
natürlich erstmal putin weil dann die
einnahmen aus den exporten noch
ansteigen das heißt es lange darüber
reden vor allen dingen das lange
hinauszögern von derartigen
entscheidungen des ankündigen dieser
entscheidungen das ist nicht günstig
einerseits steigen dann die russischen
einnahmen und zum anderen muss man ja
auch sehen und
um so transparenter wird es machen um so
mehr vorlauf hier lassen dass du erst
dann eben russland china indien möglich
andere handelswege zu organisieren und
dann wird das erleben anderen verkauft
was man natürlich auch noch sagen muss
ist das wenn man ein öl-embargo macht
wenn man wirklich verhindern will dass
das öl anderen verkauft wird kann man
das natürlich zum teil dadurch machen
dass man auch die reedereien die
schiffsflotte sagen trainiert die das
russische öl transportieren da sind ganz
viele zb griechische schiffe beteiligt
also schiffe die eben durchaus auch
aufgrund von sanktionen dann nicht mehr
fahren würden und sie hatten das vorhin
angesprochen wenn wir jetzt auch noch
mal zum gas kommen dass man da auch
tatsächlich etwas einsparen könnte ich
meine see rund 20 prozent gesagt wie
soll das genau gehen wie kann man beim
gasverbrauch einsparen ja da gibt es
eine ganze menge an maßnahmen was
absolut kontraproduktiv ist aber was im
moment geschieht ist dass die preise für
fossile energieträger sogar aktuell
reduziert werden durch verschiedene
entlastungsmaßnahmen es ist absolut
berechtigt und richtig die menschen
jetzt aktuell zu entlasten aber was man
nicht machen sollte es das zu tun indem
man die preise fossiler energieträger
sinkt denn wir brauchen jetzt diese
einsparungen die eben gerade wegen der
hohen preise stattfinden also wichtig
wäre andere kanäle zu finden den
menschen entlastung zukommen zu lassen
ohne die aktuelle relativ hohen preise
zu reduzieren
der effekt über den preismechanismus der
ist schon signifikant
es gibt zum beispiel bei
kraftstoffverbrauch eine reduktion um
11% einfach dadurch dass jetzt die
preise eine weile lang sein buch waren
die leute fahren weniger und das führt
natürlich zu geringe verbräuche bei den
privathaushalten kann man zum beispiel
sehen dass dort auch signifikante
einsparungen möglich wäre also jeder das
wurde ja jetzt schon häufig betont jeder
kann seine heizung ein bis zwei grad
runterdrehen und dann wird ein
signifikanter teil sieben bis zehn
prozent
das gas der das gas zum heizen verwendet
wird eingespart allerdings ist natürlich
so dass die privathaushalte jetzt nicht
unmittelbaren preissignal sehen um
darauf zu reagieren also die fall ist
machen die leute dass wenn man nur an
sie appelliert und da könnte man sich
geschickt und mechanismen aus lenkt man
könnte zum beispiel prämien versprechen
wenn man es schafft in diesem jahr seine
gasrechnung um einen bestimmten
prozentsatz unter die gasrechnung des
vorjahres zu drücken und wenn man da
gute prämien aus schreibt also geld auch
den tisch legt dann wäre zu erwarten
dass durchaus viele versuchen eben diese
einsparungen zu realisieren und somit
auch die prämien zu kassieren
das hat natürlich doppelten nutzen die
leute bekommen eine entlastung und auf
der anderen seite wäre der gast habe
auch eingeschränkt dann kann man auch
andere sachen machen in der industrie
gibt es viele möglichkeiten wo man auch
kurzfristig umsteigen kann wo man sehr
alte heizkessel austauschen kann da gibt
es vielfältige möglichkeiten man müsste
eben einen aktionsplan in der effizienz
jetzt initiieren um das wirklich
konzertiert voranzutreiben und sofort
eben auch das eingesparte gastland
eingespeichert damit man vorwand für den
nächsten winter hat und dann zum schluss
noch die frage also wenn energie
sanktionen kommen sollten und dass dann
auch einschnitte mit sich bringt kann
deutschland sich darauf aber auch
irgendwie vorbereiten
ja genau also das vorbereiten würde eben
stattfinden durch das
durch das organisieren von
ersatzlieferungen auf der einen seite
und durch die einsparungen und dadurch
diese beiden maßnahmen würde man
versuchen diese lücke so weit wie
möglich zu schließen er jetzt vor der
vor dem angriff auch die ukraine war der
anteil des russischen gases an den
deutschen gasverbrauchs ungefähr 40
prozent zwar schon von 55 auf 40 prozent
runter gegangen schon vor dem krieg
einfach deswegen weil russland ja nur
noch die mindestmengen geliefert hat und
deswegen hat hatte russland selbst da
schon ein teil zu den einsparungen
beitragen und diese 40 prozent könnte
man jetzt eben reduzieren dadurch dass
man teilen ersetzt wahrscheinlich könnte
man so um die 15 prozent vielleicht zum
beispiel über ersatzbeschaffungen
realisieren man kann bis zu 20 prozent
einsparen man sieht die lücke die dann
bliebe wenn man das alles perfekt macht
die wäre gar nicht so groß aber die
erwartung dass das alles so klappt wie
man sich das auf dem reißbrett ausdenken
kann dies natürlich auch nicht da danke
für diese einschätzung heute abend an
professor doktor veronika grimm eine der
wirtschaftsweisen vielen dank ich danke
ihnen
und ob es also zunächst ging es ja mal
konkret um das öl-embargo der eu gegen
russland ob es dazu kommen sollte das
beobachten wir natürlich auch in den
weiteren tagen für euch und sind
jederzeit wieder live danke für eure
aufmerksamkeit und bis dahin tschüss